how better to police the financial
interests of former European
commissioners with faith in the EU lo
and tax avoidance stalking its agenda
commissioners need to be seen as pure
than pure per gallon on pure got cows
and become the sky fuel distribution
empty Tyler der gesellschaft Hadid are
open yummy guns under Vega and gettin
under lizette sir alfred e nom alpha
power via as false for later and we'll
focus up later missing tame sotif stand
getting any piece debated conflicts of
interest of past and present
commissioners after the Bahamas papers
exposed former Competition Commissioner
Nellie cruces directorship of a firm
registered in the Caribbean tax haven
while she was in post lady consequence
in city commissioners vas cindy zhang
jian de griffin be enjoyed soil they
just African Franklin's urgent situation
the reputation of the EU also took a hit
when former President Jose Manuel
Barroso accepted a job at the American
bank Goldman Sachs seen as a key player
in the 2008 global financial crisis
chief a oz eau de la cruz de todo correo
pea sauce lezhot go septic Omaha
Monsieur fog azuma Dom lepen you laser
go cynic commercial bako zoo m aramco's
ski clase premier ganyani Teja on that
is Allah correct sushi tei pero como
tomar a dinner date soo geun a code of
conduct forbids commissioners from
holding outside directorships mrs. Cruz
who has three paid consultancies with
American companies described her failure
over her previous directorship as an
oversight for which she takes full
responsibility
my tips together